[Musik]
das klappt jetzt bekommen bei einer
neuen video
ich hoffe euch jetzt gut weg ist sehr
gut ich bin gestern aus dem urlaub
wiedergekommen und ich habe mir gedacht
alex jetzt oder nie als erste mal
gelesen wir fangen einfach ab jetzt an
eine woche möchte dass wir das aller
letzte sein was ich dazu machen werde
also zu diesem eine woche jeden was die
haben wirklich so extrem gewünscht
deswegen gibt es jetzt ich will gar
nicht lange lagern die wochen steht mega
viel an
ich fliege erst hamburger gewähren wird
gerade montag das ganze geht dann
logischerweise sonntag und da werden wir
noch aus dieser wohnung ausziehen und
denn die neue wirklich richtig richtig
eine wohnung ziehen dann kann ich
eigentlich nicht so viel zu zeigen weil
da kommt dann sitzen also ich möchte
mich eine woche klarheit und ich würde
nicht klar wann wir fangen andere und
das hier ist mein vater also was soll
man sagen muss hat keine ahnung was
erzählt mehrere sektor der woche war
schmerzhaft
[Musik]
hero leute zu einem mega light also das
hättest du mir leid ich konnte nichts
für uns hat die heute mega wichtigen
dreh und spricht vom kölner hingeflogen
und das ging sofort los ich hatte
absolut keine zeit für irgendwas
spazieren wunderschöne zellen mit einer
wunder wunderschöne aussicht hier ist
ein dach oder so und deswegen geht das
ganze erst jetzt los also ich wollte es
eigentlich erst mal kurz nach weil ich
bin müde und dann fange ich an
da habe ich auch zu einer kurzen tour da
ist und fernseher
da ist ein berg hier ist ein zuletzt
vier den spiegel und stünde dann ist
wahrscheinlich schon dunkel sie haben
einfach von 8 uhr gleich so leiste was
ich habe einfach eingeschlafen das vage
da so dumm weil ich jetzt gleich nicht
schlagen kann ich weiß es passt auf wir
haben jetzt ohne spaß bei 1 von 2 46
und ich hab einfach drei hat schon
geschlafen oder so aber ich drehe sich
um die ecke lesen möchte auf jeden fall
jetzt natürlich und jetzt das ganze also
das wetter ist auf jeden fall
dementsprechend geil
unter mir würde jetzt eine woche kürzer
machen darf
erfunden er ist ohne spaß meine ganze
kamera ist deshalb so krass geregnet
auch sagen ich erreicht hunger möchte
erstmal die gurke roter thun eltern so
geregnet
sogar dieses getränk ist durch gewalt
zugang zu fernsehen und dann wünsche
euch eine angenehme gute nacht und ich
hoffe ich kann gut schlafen aber
bestimmt was geht leute guten morgen ich
habe gar schon geduscht und wir haben
jetzt 10 uhr ist es gleich zurück nach
köln
es muss ein bisschen beeilen und jetzt
muss natürlich erst mal flüchtigen ich
hoffe ich finde in hamburg am flughafen
mcus ich weiß nicht ob ich schaffe wenn
ich nicht aber dann haben wir werden
sehen
ich muss jetzt ganz nett packen dann
geht's los gleichen regeln zu gestreift
also ich nicht verstehen können wir
angekommen
ich weiß ganz viel von den freien fall
ist jetzt meistens
[Musik]
[Applaus]
keine ahnung
[Musik]
entweder in die menschen und das land
damit gleich schon soweit den watt guten
morgen bzw wir haben schon nicht mehr
morgen das ding wir sind ergänzen jetzt
wir umgezogen ich will ja noch gar
nichts zu viel zeigen auf jeden fall hat
das bistro gedauert dann musste ich
erstmal schlaf nachholen weil ich habe
das volk nächte auf echtes lange
geschlafen und es ist natürlich auch
noch nicht alles ganz fertig aber das
meiste mir zu mir zurück zum thema
theoretisch müsste ich jetzt erst mal
frühstücken das ding ist jetzt locker
kleinen frühstück ergeben ich weiß aber
auch sofort zu meinen eltern weil ich zu
hause ein termin habe und übermorgen
vielleicht dann wieder zurück nach köln
habe ich auf jeden fall jetzt mega mal
gucken was es so gibt ich glaube ich
schon immer irgendwas von diesem mccafé
und vielleicht mal so ein zwei sätze
dazu wie es mir so geht also ich meine
es mache das jetzt seit 48 schon nicht
mal 36 stunden also und alles cool ist
für mich noch topfit ich wahrscheinlich
noch ändern
aber an sich ist alles cool natürlich
ist das schon immer so ein bisschen
eklig wenn man einen tag zweimal
hintereinander dann fast ist für mich
der film toll normalen bereich innerhalb
von 40 minuten von hier hinzu kommt dass
es bei keiner verkehrszeichen nicht
immer einfach
[Musik]
wirklich
du spielst
328 nacht weil ich hätte gern ein
wegschicken classic menu de fanti bitte
dann einmal betreiber was gibt's noch
als alternative zu pommes nämlich ja
genau so etwas wird heftigst noch nie
probiert bin ich mal gespannt so leicht
auf jeden fall haben ja schon vorstellen
später ich habe hier mein abendessen
wegschicken classics maß und spaß noch
nie gegessen und ich bin jetzt
dementsprechend gespannt wieder schmeckt
auch so und ich hoffe hier einfach mal
ja dieses sour cream sind eigentlich zur
potato wedges ein bisschen macdonald
endlich wissen aber schmeckt echt mal
gucken wie auch die spieler in den
kommentaren leser um mein gott jetzt
habe ich mir schmeckt auf jeden fall gut
mehr kann ich dazu auch nicht sagen wir
mal gespannt wie das ganze morgen
aussieht als erster sein ich hatte es
nicht so megawatt darauf arbeitet ist
okay das schmeckt alles kriegt wünscht
eine gute nacht
[Musik]
eher leute dass es so heftig ich hab
einfach schon wieder recht geschafft
früchte zu gehen ich muss doch mal
frühstück
[Musik]
die einst war
sorry aber ihr könnt gar nicht wirklich
das war das schlechteste ist jeder mac
ist ersten ab und ich bin schon alt
genug also selbst schon viele
einzelheiten aber leute was guten morgen
ich hoffe ihr könnt mich gut verstehen
weil es da ging ein bisschen jetzt nicht
so die optimale kameraposition ich bin
jetzt gerade aufgestanden wir haben
freitag ich mach das ganze jetzt seit
vier tagen und ich muss sagen ich bin
auf jeden fall schon mal mit mehr
energie wach geworden aber ich bin echt
überrascht das ist wirklich das muss man
sich mal vorstellen oder ich finds von
krass weil ich mache das jetzt seit vier
tagen bei vier tage nicht nur fast food
und dann nur macdonald also ich hätte
mir das auf jeden fall bis jetzt um
einiges schwerer vorgestellt
aber wir haben ja auch noch so
zweieinhalb tage bis sonntag ich weiß
sofort wieder zurück nach köln oder
gleich erst nach düsseldorf weil ich mir
noch ein auto anschauen weil ich
eigentlich jetzt mein auto brauche 8
takt es kann doch nicht sein
wer mit locker ich habe auch ein leben
der nächsten semesterferien deswegen
kann ich mal so lange schlafen das
frühstück habe ich schon wieder
also ich glaube bei männern kann man bis
1 verfrühstücken er wenn ich das bis
sonntag nicht hinkriege einmal dazu
flüchtigen ich habe seit fünf tagen und
spaß nicht gefrühstückt naja wir sehen
uns gleich so leute manchmal zum bahnhof
gebracht
und es gibt erst mal zu mcdonald
feststellen daß mein papa
alle die die burka nicht nur im wird man
dann nach oben
wir tragen
aus dieser gruppe
zugenommen woher weiß man so besonders
wenn wir klein waren und jetzt läuft es
einfach eine woche lang jeden tag nur
leute deshalb sein ist gar nichts mit
dem eigentlichen videos immer zu tun
aber den platz von tellabs und ich freue
mich mega das muss einfach sagen es noch
nicht
über 200 habe ich noch wieder feiern
weil es einfach an sich nicht braucht
aber an sich natürlich schon praktisch
und das hat super funktioniert
wünsch euch nur sagen der welthunger
begehrt werk zu merken
das video
ein spiel und spaß
ich habe absolut keinen bock mehr in
saytrust als ich will aus anderes essen
gehen so läuft heute wieder mega
anstrengen das ist ja auch gleichzeitig
mehr laut auf jeden fall bin ich jetzt
endlich in köln angekommen ist gerade
auf unserem wunderschönen nein da kann
[Musik]
das passieren
noch kritischer es kommt mir so langsam
welche aus den ohren raus also heute
morgen ist jetzt wirklich der letzte tag
von einem ist wirklich hart und ja
gerade habe ich recht ich brauche
irgendwie so ein bisschen vitamin oder
sowas brauchen also auch gefallen ist
ich habe hier an der haut immer sonne
stelle ich weiß nicht vielleicht habt
ihr es auch mal gesehen und manchmal ist
die halt weg und gerade ist ja extrem da
weil ich mich glaube ich nicht so gut
ernähre aber auch mal dazu sagen muss
ich hätte es echt viel viel schlimmer
erwartet dass gutes es gibt strategien
zu ihrem mac mini
das sind jetzt nicht die einzelnen sich
habe ich hab echt auch sie mehr als 90
wir sehen uns morgen ich wollte heute
aber wieder rausgehen können ich weiß
länger nicht hier mit meinen freunden
die ich mit ihr habt haut rein
bis morgen dann morgen diese zahl von so
unglaublich schnell hoch was die
fachleute schon morgen
wir haben jetzt wieder ein bisschen
später ich bin jetzt gerade dann auch
mal aufgestanden und ich bin wirklich so
froh wenn der tag heute eigentlich
vorbei ist weil man hat es geschafft
alter um ehrlich zu sein jetzt mehr auf
echtes gut könnte auch daran liegen dass
ich viel zu wenig schlaf weil ich es mit
zurückgekommen bin war aber ganz ehrlich
ist hier ist jetzt noch durch und dann
schafft so eckl tja meine kommentare
freilich noch gut aus oder sich ungesund
ernährt aus oder wie sich auf online ist
mir gerade mal so gedacht so eigentlich
braucht sie auch irgendwann mal von
vergleich zu einer anderen fahrt
sudkessel ob das dann anders ist oder
wie auch immer weil gerade wirklich so
ich kann jetzt nicht sage ich hab das ja
auch schon mit pizza gemacht da war es
nach sieben tag eigentlich egal da ich
auch noch länger pizzaessen könnt weil
man sich wohl gefühlt hat aber gerade
zurzeit echt überhaupt nicht der fall
nur wie würde das aussehen bei subway
oder kfc oder so canaria
glaube ich wird der ersten star
präsentieren ich könnte mir vorstellen
dass da vielleicht erst länger geht es
wenn ihr bock gehabt dass ich das
irgendwann mal testete jetzt vielleicht
nicht in den nächsten zwei wochen nach
oder so dass wir dann nach oben dabei
jetzt muss ich eigentlich ausholen bei
30.000 leicht machen wir das jetzt
schaue ich mal diese macdonald auf jeden
fall habe ich das gerade das kamel
gemacht und ich muss heute noch zweimal
im monat euch auf jeden fall nicht das
kann ich natürlich nicht alles selber
essen ich hab es ja schon öfter mal
gemacht dass wenn ich halte was hier in
köln holen oder so man kann das auch
ganz einfach dann obdachlosen geben oder
so die sich darüber sehr freuen also ich
kann jetzt schlecht für mac minis essen
wie auch schon gesagt eigentlich am
liebsten gar nichts mehr davon aber nur
wenn es jetzt vorgelegt worden sind sind
wer von euch hat jetzt hunger müssen
jetzt mal ehrlich ich will das auch
selber machen durch negative folgen
hätte ich jetzt endlich das zu fahren
und das habe ich hier noch getränke also
ich hoffe dass sie dadurch gefallen hat
nach oben auf jeden fall bis ins tal
ich habe absolut keinen bock mehr ich
würde mal sagen irgendwann reißen und
das war echt so die grenze wir sehen uns
morgen wieder mal ein komplettes video
und ja ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
irgendwann gibt es vielleicht mal subway
wenn ich zu viel langeweile hat und
zweiten reihe sorgen für nicht alles
selber gegessen